SPEAKER 1: MacArthur
criticized Truman publicly,
said there is no
substitute for victory.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There wasn't much time after the
victory over Germany and Japan
for popping champagne
corks and celebrating.
Just as the 50 nations that had
joined in defeating the Axis
powers were drafting a
charter for the United Nations
in San Francisco,
victorious alliance
between the United States
and the Soviet Union
was falling apart.
War alliance between
the United States
and Britain and the Soviet
Union was tactical exclusively.
There was no other ideological
or sentimental attachment
between the nations.
And as the war appeared to be
won in Europe, spring of 1945,
the Red Army began occupying
more and more portions
of Eastern Europe with the
clear intention of establishing
a Soviet Empire.
This is exactly what
Churchill was worried about.
In March of 1946,
Winston Churchill
gave a speech in America in
which he uttered a phrase that
would live on for a long time.
He said that "from
Stettin in the Baltic
to Trieste in the Adriatic,
an Iron Curtain has descended
across the continent."
So what to do about this
expansionist tendency,
short of fighting a war?
Well, what Truman arrived
at was a conclusion heavily
influenced by the
writings of George Kennan,
an American diplomat
in Russia, who
believed that Soviet
expansionism was actually
a result of the insecure,
unstable nature of the regime
itself, and that the
process of expansion
was actually a way of
holding that regime together.
And that if expansion was
prevented, if it was contained,
then the regime, in
due course, would
turn in on itself and collapse.
This doctrine came to
be known as containment,
because it was a way of fighting
the Soviet regime by containing
it rather than by defeating it.
At any rate, a
sustained confrontation
between the two
remaining superpowers
in the world that would come
to be called the Cold War.
The Cold War turned hot in
1950 on the Korean Peninsula,
which had been
divided since the end
of the war between
communist forces
in the north that were
aligned with the Soviet Union
and Democratic
forces in the South
that were aligned with
the United States.
This led to an invasion
on June 25, 1950
of some 80,000 North
Korean troops that
swept into the South,
very nearly conquering it.
And Truman invoked
the United Nations.
And the American response was
funneled through the United
Nations, as it was
called a police
action rather than a war.
There was no declaration of war.
The war went very badly until
General Douglas MacArthur
got involved, performed a
brilliant amphibious invasion
at Inchon, which cut off
the North Korean troops
and led him quickly to
be able to around them
up, defeat them,
and then head north.
And they kept going north
and finally approached
the Chinese border.
And at that point, a quarter
of a million Chinese troops
swept in on MacArthur and drove
him back into South Korea,
with the battle line
finally stabilizing
around the 38th parallel.
At this point,
MacArthur and Truman
got deadlocked in a conflict,
because MacArthur thought
the time was right,
the justification
was there for what he
called a whole new war--
a war against China,
against communist China,
that would succeed
in overthrowing
this unfriendly, hostile,
noxious communist regime that
had just taken
power and thus avert
the prospect of a Sino-Soviet
Chinese and Soviet alliance
that could come to
dominate the world.
The time was right
to take that on.
Truman, on the
other hand, thought
this was absolutely
the wrong thing--
that it would be, he
called it, a booby trap
to go into a war in China
and rejected the idea.
MacArthur criticized
Truman publicly.
In an official letter to
the House Minority Leader,
said there is no
substitute for victory--
in other words, a rejection
of the containment doctrine.
There is no
prettifying the fact,
though, that the Korean War
was, at best, a stalemate.
It remains a people divided.
To this day, there is no
settlement of the war.
The war is simply suspended.
So in some ways,
it illustrates some
of the unsatisfactory aspects
of the containment doctrine.
And that situation is
yet to be resolved.
SPEAKER 2: Thank
you for watching.
We hope you're enjoying
our Highlights series
and invite you to explore
all of Hillsdale College's
online courses.
They are free and for
everyone who loves to learn.